es un recordatorio el tremendo
sacrificio que los soldados a veces
hacen mientras sirven a su país tres
soldados franceses murieron el lunes en
mali cuando un explosivo golpeó por
sorpresa su vehículo durante una
operación militar el palacio del elíseo
publicó estas fotos de los tres
en un comunicado la oficina del
presidente francés honró la memoria de
los soldados con el mayor de los
respetos y destacó el compromiso de
francia de luchar contra el terrorismo
esto ocurrió en la región malí de
hombori los soldados estaban operando en
la zona como parte de la operación
francesa para quien que busca expulsar a
los yihadistas de la región del sahel
francia intervino por primera vez en
enero de 2013 cuando los yihadistas
tomaron el control de varias zonas del
país las muertes de los soldados se
elevan a 47 el total de soldados
franceses caídos en mali unas 5.100
tropas están repartidas por la árida
región del sahel combaten a los
yihadistas junto a los soldados
provenientes de mauritania chad burkina
faso y níger quienes conforman el grupo
de países g5 en el sahel